let's talk about everyone's big hope a
corona virus vaccine for all and
treatments for the sick
hundreds of vaccines and drugs are being
tested around the world in record time
what we're trying to do so take
something that usually takes 15 years
and truncate it down to a few months we
all have questions and some of you send
us Wars when can we expect a vaccine who
will get it first how much will it cost
and here's one from us do we need a
vaccine to get back to our normal lives
[Music]
there is no cure for Tsarskoe v2 the
corona virus that causes the disease
covin 19 but a vaccine and the right
drugs can help our bodies fight it so
this is what we're up against the virus
has a crown of spikes made of protein
molecules they attach to human cells and
act like a key in a lock that lets the
virus in once inside the virus hijacks
the cells reproductive machinery to make
copies of itself a vaccine protects you
by mimicking a small part of the virus
we would take a little part of that
protein surface of the virus killing the
virus and we would inject it into people
to see if they would make antibodies to
it if that real virus came in then the
antibody would immediately recognize it
and it would immediately take care of it
but there are different ways of making a
vaccine some labs are taking the more
traditional route their testing whether
introducing different parts of the spike
protein into humans can trigger an
immune response but this sort of protein
based vaccine typically takes years to
develop because scientists have to grow
the protein and test it safe so other
labs are working on a different strategy
that's never been done before it
involves copying a small section of the
virus's RNA genetic code and injecting
that into a person that RNA fragment
then instructs human cells to reproduce
certain coronavirus proteins and
hopefully that triggers an immune
response using the RNA approach means
you don't have to grow the corona virus
protein in a lab the body does all the
hard work hopefully this will take
months out of the process and will give
us a vaccine sooner but again we're in
uncharted territory here now usually a
vaccine takes up to 10 or even 15 years
test manufacture and distribute if a
vaccine candidate even makes it that far
but we don't have that kind of time
[Music]
dozens of laboratories are now
battlegrounds in the race for a vaccine
labs around the world got to work as
soon as a Chinese scientist published
the virus's genetic sequence in January
we've been working on this with all
cylinders we're kind of writing the
PlayBook past the game is being played
it's a game with high-stakes
government's public institutions
philanthropists they're all involved
private companies in places like the US
China and Germany they're all competing
but some researchers are also working
together on open platforms we haven't
seen such an acceleration in sharing
information and sharing data to give you
an idea of how fast things are moving it
took seven months to start human trials
during the Zika epidemic that was a
record for this new corona virus it took
just 63 days the testing on people is
just one step the manufacturing I think
is going to be the real challenge and we
need to make sure that we're raving that
up right now alongside of the clinical
trials that are underway based on most
estimates we could get a new vaccine
sometime early next year but it'll take
longer for it to get to millions of
people one of the vaccine makers Johnson
& Johnson says that won't happen before
late next year and there's going to be a
bottleneck so who gets it first
during the h1n1 swine flu in 2009 one of
the first vaccines was made in Australia
the government was criticized for making
sure it went to Australians first the
concern this time around is that
countries will want to do the same thing
again and there's reason for that
concern President Trump has been accused
of trying to lure a German
pharmaceutical company working on a
corona virus vaccine to the US German
authorities insist that no country
should have a monopoly that is offering
its own financial incentives for the
vaccine to stay in the country right now
there is no international body to police
distribution of a vaccine
not even the w-h-o has that power nor is
there a global plan for a coordinated
rollout groups like the GAVI vaccine
Alliance and sepi though are working to
get vaccines to developing countries and
the w-h-o has emergency rules in place
that were set up during the Ebola
epidemic they say any new vaccine should
first go to the people who need it most
like frontline workers the frontline of
the health care workers and clearly
older and vulnerable populations that's
going to be the first phase and then
wider mass mobilization would happen
after that there's also pressure on the
pharmaceutical industry not to chase big
profits millions of people need the
vaccine so the demand will be huge and
governments can't afford to pay top
dollar
the thing is vaccines are expensive to
make in terms of the actual opportunity
it's fairly limited the margins are
typically razor thin it's very hard to
scale the production in any meaningful
and profitable way
sepi and the Wellcome Trust think it'll
cost the industry
three billion dollars to develop
manufacture and distribute a vaccine
globally it might be worthwhile for a
private company to make it have a good
standing in the public eye to say we're
going to do this at a reduced cost this
is a humanitarian thing the Gates
Foundation is likely going to blow
billions of dollars to build production
facilities for seven vaccine candidate
knowing some of those vaccines won't
make the grade
the idea is to ensure we're ready to go
once a vaccine is found we'll make it as
cheap as we can and there's no doubt the
money will be should be found to buy
that vaccine for everyone on the planet
a vaccine is the long term goal so right
now scientists are using experimental
treatments to help people already sick
with Kovan 19:00 like plasma therapy
which involves collecting antibodies
from people who've recovered and
injecting them into infected patients
they're also trying out drugs in early
development or already on the market for
other diseases like the antiviral REM
des aveer that was developed for Ebola
or hydroxychloroquine used for malaria
there are many candidates therapeutics
or drugs that are showing some promise
or potential but we need to be
exceptionally careful it's extremely
important that we rely on the results
that are going to come from trials that
will tell us how safe and how effective
these drugs are and then there are the
so-called treatments that have raised
alarm bells
I see the disinfectant it knocks it out
in a minute
one minute and is there way we can do
something like that by injection inside
the idea of injecting disinfectant got
lots of laughs online I think most
people are smart enough to know that
they shouldn't be taking medical or
public health advice from President
Trump they should be listening to expert
opinion with every vaccine or drug
there's a calculated risk with measles
for instance your chance of dying from
the disease is about one in a thousand
but the chances of having an adverse
reaction to the vaccine are less than
one in a million
any medical response is going to be
experimental and might come with side
effects because no drug or vaccine has
been licensed for this coronavirus it's
new but we also know that vaccines have
saved millions of lives
I would like to declare 26 October as
small part zero day mumps measles the
Asian flu all those epidemics that
killed hundreds of millions of people
are nearly all gone now experimental
vaccines were also used to fight Ebola
and that epidemic has largely been
contained the ultimate goal is to slam
the brakes on the virus's ability to
spread and building immunity is key at
the moment one infected person gives it
to roughly three other people who each
infect three more and so on but if we
create what's called herd immunity we
can bring that write down the idea is
for about sixty percent of people to
become immune to the corona virus either
by recovering from it or getting
vaccinated that way we reduce
transmission from one person to just one
other person or less the key is to get
to sixty percent as fast as possible
that strain of the virus will now no
longer be a threat and it will go away
but we aren't there yet which is why the
experts say it'll be awhile before life
can return to normal if we have one time
social distancing there's a very good
chance that a large number of people
will remain susceptible to infection it
seems like naturally we're going to
enter into this intermittent social
distancing period and in order to reach
a high enough level of immunity in the
population our models suggest that it
could take into 2022 it's also worth
remembering that until we get those
treatments and a vaccine most of us
around 80% can rely on our own immune
systems to fight the corona virus so the
general advice is to stay healthy eat
well sleep well and exercise even if
you're stuck at home because
that's where we need to be right now to
protect people who are most at risk
while we all wait for the science to
catch up we don't know when we'll be
back on the start here set but not to
worry we're still going to be bringing
you more episodes anyway we can in the
meantime our website aljazeera.com has
all the latest on the corona virus
pandemic I'll see you next week
[Music]